eighty percent of our inner dialogue is
negative and 95 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts that we had yesterday
that's what Beth Handel taught me she's
garyvee's life coach we had an awesome
session together and it really hit home
imagine that 80 of the thoughts that
you've got 80 are negative we are
beating ourselves up we're telling
ourselves that we can't do things it's
not even our friends and family people
around us telling us that we suck it's
us it's ourselves we tell ourselves
we're not good enough we can't do this
we're not strong enough smart enough
we're from the wrong country we look the
wrong way we're too young we're too old
whatever it is 80 of our thoughts are
negative and then 95 of those negative
thoughts are the exact same negative
thoughts that we had yesterday it's no
wonder why we stay small it's no wonder
why we stay stuck because we've created
this reinforcing Loop of negativity